did you spot all of the harry potter
stars who appeared in enola homes
and what about that reference to lord
voldemort the film features tons of
witches and wizards from the harry
potter series but there are also a few
subtle connections to the wizarding
world
for example they have a writer in common
the music was inspired
by harry potter and enola uses a few of
harry's tricks to get to the bottom of
her own grand mystery
plus anola and harry are kindred spirits
who both grew up feeling alone
with relatives who'd rather they didn't
exist here are all the potter
connections you might have missed in the
nola homes
but be warned that there are some
spoilers ahead
i had to see for myself if the rumors
were true let's start with some familiar
faces helena bonham carter is the genius
actress who plays eudoria homes inola
sherlock and mycroft's mother
we're sure you recognize her as
bellatrix lestrange sirius black's
cousin
and one of voldemort's favorite and most
sinister death eaters
your bloodlust bellatrix i must be the
one to kill harry potter
helena might not be playing a wicked
witch in this flick but she definitely
has some connections to her harry potter
character
mainly she joins a secret society to try
and start a revolution
this secret society might have more
noble causes than being a death eater
well done drank
but eudoria's radical way of thinking
and her longing for freedom could
definitely be inspired by bellatrix
there are two pearls you can take an
ella yours
or the path others choose for you even
if we can't say many nice things about
her at least she always goes after
exactly what she wants the next familiar
face is another
let's just say unpleasant harry potter
character fiona shaw plays
miss harrison the headmistress of the
finishing school where nola definitely
doesn't want to be
miss harrison is a tough woman and plans
to make enola into exactly who society
thinks she should be
i want you to live a full and vibrant
life
she definitely reminds us of her harry
potter character petunia dursley
except she's tutoring porynola instead
of harry miss harrison doesn't seem
terrible all the time
she actually seems like she enjoys the
challenge a wild girl like in nola
presents
in comparison and petunia definitely
didn't like harry's heritage coming up
in her life and she would have much
rather a simple muggle existence without
her pesky magical nephew getting in the
way
he would be the same just as strange
just as
abnormal francis de la tour is probably
the hardest star to recognize from her
harry potter days
let's just say that her character in the
potter universe was larger than life and
brought a certain french sophistication
to hogwarts
got any guesses in enola homes she plays
the sinister dowager but in harry potter
frances was the one and only madame
maxine the half-giant headmistress of
bobaton's academy of magic who ended up
crushing hard on hagrid
dressed in black and looking fairly
somber her role as the dowager is very
different from the colorful and quaffed
maxine
you were dressed differently then maybe
the dowager is so upset because she's
stuck caring about voter reform instead
of which of her young witches will win
the triwizard tournament
first person to touch the cup will be
the winner
let's go behind the scenes a little jack
thorne penned the script for enola
holmes and there might be a reason he
was so smitten with former harry potter
cast mates and those magical adventure
elements he infused
throughout the film jack is also a
co-author of harry potter and the cursed
child
the stage play follow-up to jk rowling's
original series
jack infused a lot of potter elements
into the script like a beautiful train
ride that sets our hero
off on her grand journey since jack
wrote about a bunch of magical kids
before
it's not hard to see that he's got a
talent for bringing out the wild and
free side of his teenage characters who
set off to find something bigger than
themselves in a new and confusing world
well that's unexpected
anola and her mother definitely love
word games anagrams are used throughout
the movie to give enola clues about
where eudoria has gone
they're even used to explain her name
which backwards spells
alone an anagram is also the method jk
rowling uses to reveal the origin
of the one and only lord voldemort in
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
rowling demonstrates that the letters in
i am lord voldemort can be rearranged to
read
tom marvolo riddle which is how harry
found out who opened the chamber of
secrets in the first place
anagrams aren't universal to the harry
potter series of course but it is
interesting that anagrams help both
harry
and nola discover what's really going on
the answer is often right in front of
you after all
all you have to do is learn how to
decipher it
you have to make some noise if you want
to be heard
if you notice that the enola home
soundtrack has a certain magical feel
to it then you'd be exactly right daniel
pemberton is the genius composer behind
enola homes and he described the film by
saying
it's kind of got the sort of magic of
harry potter a lot of the exciting tunes
that were playing while lanola and the
marquess were escaping danger
were inspired by the memorable music
from the wizarding films
enola might not have spells in her
arsenal but she still has out of this
world adventures that deserve some
exhilarating theme songs
when looking to travel incognito it's
safest to travel as a widow
like harry potter enola has an entire
popular book series depicting her many
exciting adventures
the anola homes movie isn't just based
on sir arthur conan doyle's original
sherlock series which already has many
adaptations
this time henry cavill comes in to take
on the iconic role of sherlock holmes
but this
is definitely not his story oh i do
believe she thought in me
the movie is specifically based on nancy
springer's series of mysteries starring
sherlock's little sister
anola the first book in the enola homes
mysteries
series is called the case of the missing
marquess there's a lot of material there
to work with when it comes to sequels
and the creators of anola are definitely
planning on making a franchise out of
this one
just like the harry potter series the
books are beloved by young readers
everywhere
and netflix might just pull a warner
brothers and turn anola into the biggest
teenage film franchise of the 2020s
of course the movie isn't just like the
books so here are some interesting
changes made to the source material
enola's age was changed from 14 to 16
while the marquess was only supposed to
be 12.
also enola never actually attended the
boarding school in the books and eudoria
wasn't part of a secret society
rather she left to become a romantic
gypsy and find her freedom
outside of motherhood the changes
definitely make the movie a little more
adult
and also make us sympathize with eudoria
a little more than we would have if she
was just running away to have fun
while leaving anola to fend for herself
tennis
mother says i'm getting quite proficient
let's break down the plot of anola homes
just a little
let's see a sheltered teenager leaves
home for the first time on her own
only to find out that she must take on a
mystery much bigger than herself
hmm doesn't that sound familiar we can
definitely see where harry potter and
nola holmes connect as two kindred
spirits
trying to free themselves from what
binds them while also saving the world
in this case enola wasn't just saving
herself and the marquess from danger
but also saving the vote for citizens
all over the uk
and just like harry potter who knows
what she'll do next
it's also important to point out that
harry ends up with two reluctant family
members taking care of him once he loses
his
parents up get up
now and anola suffers the same fate with
her two brothers
another connection between harry and
danola harry wasn't a wizard
that he knew of before he left privet
drive and headed out to hogwarts
there he learned to practice magic and
become a true wizard
and nola's journey is similar she wasn't
a detective before she set off to london
i'm a private detective and i've come to
offer my services by the end of the film
she's tracked down her mother and saved
the marquess both her and harry stepped
into brand new worlds and became brand
new people
and neither ever turned back by the end
of the movie anola has a much clearer
idea of who she is
and bids farewell by saying i am a
detective
i am a decipherer and i am a finder of
lost
souls daniel radcliffe skyrocketed to
fame with his role in the harry potter
series
he was only 11 and immediately became
one of the most well-known actors of his
generation
we can already see the same thing
happening with millie bobby brown
she earned her prime time emmy award
nomination for outstanding supporting
actress in a drama series at age 13 for
playing 11
in stranger things she is also the
youngest person
ever to be featured on time's 100 list
why not and with her own film franchise
underway she might soon make in nola
homes as famous as harry potter is
all over the world do you think canola
homes is the next harry potter
let us know what you love or hate about
the character in the comment section
down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
you